but not like the guy from CNN
what's-his-face yeah red brain reza
aslan yeah he'll never live that down I
think it really messed him up I do
because he's become a really awful
person really and I think it's not that
he ate human meat human brain okay I
think it's that he's be he's been
shunned so somewhat like because of it
yeah and so he's got friends who were in
high places so he still gets to exist in
society as like a wealthy individual and
he's super rich hmm but he gets torn up
all the time as the guy who ate brain
and so you see his reaction to things
like with the covenant kids he's like I
want to punch it out you know he's like
I've ever seen a more punchable face and
post a picture of a fourteen-year-old
kid it's like dude chill out but I think
he's be it's like anger I think it's
it's it's like it's almost like he was
cancelled hmm like when that segment
came out where he ate brain everyone was
like you are a disgusting piece of human
filth yep and he'll never never escape
he is trapped in this world it was funny
I was talking to somebody who knows
ain't human brain what do you expect man
check check it out
I was talking to somebody who knows him
okay and they brought him up and I was
like what isn't
isn't he a cannibal and they were like
he is not a cannibal and I was like he
ate human meat yeah he ate a little bit
of brain for a show and I'm like that
makes him a cannibal yeah they are you
know cannibals
like are people who eat human meat is
like a thing they do and I was like so
saying me if like an old dude diddle
okay just one time you're not gonna call
him out as a pedo yeah and they're well
I'm like yeah reza aslan ate brain he's
a cannibal yeah yeah we're done here
yeah there's no station overs no he's
almost again no you literally did it
yeah exactly
but I think they really messed him up
yeah cuz he even look like what we're
saying about it yeah he can't escape it
could you imagine being trapped in that
world if it change your name change your
appearance mm-hmm give up everything
you're always gonna be the dude who ate
human on TV this is a public service
announcement brought to you by me don't
eat human meat
you know what's really you know it's
really crazy about it is that I think
this was like a CNN show and what they
claim is that he was scared for his life
and kind of like forced to do it because
the the tribalists who mate who made him
like horror cooking the brain or
like dangerous okay you know what I
think the real reason why they did it
was why they wanted to be vice yeah okay
dude vice had a segment where Ryan Duffy
goes down to I think I came over at
Columbia or something and he's trying
out bulletproof clothing and they
literally shoot him
dang and the bullet just flops down and
he's like wow it was a really big thick
like trench coat I barely remember the
episode but they also did the
scopolamine thing you know it's Coppola
Mina's mmm it's this it's this drug
where they like blow it in your face and
then it turns you into a combined --less
drunk yeah that does whatever okay no of
this so vice does all these like dark
edgy documentaries that were extremely
popular on YouTube right when they do
that series and then they get HBO and
they get all these Emmys and then
everyone and their mother wanted to be
Vice I'm not kidding I know why I got
higher division through it yeah I'm
watched it so so Fusion tries poaching
me and they're like you know we want it
we want to do what they do and all this
stuff we want to yeah and I'm like yeah
sure sure I got you man then they
quickly changed their tune but I
actually got called down to a meeting
with a bunch of people and they said how
do we do what vice does and I had some
choice words for these these
corporations but this was around the
same time CNN was trying to do these
Verte like travel dock stuff dude eats
brain and it was really obvious I mean
for me as somebody who worked for Vice I
was like it's kind of like if you're you
know I don't know how many people can
relate to this but you're like an
in-school and there's that one dorky kid
who's kind of like you know loser who's
desperately trying to fit in
yeah and so like you're you're sitting
with your friends and also need walks up
and says something really awkward and
you're sitting there like alright dude
that yeah sure anyway then you like turn
back to your friends yeah that's what it
was could you imagine like destroying
your life because you were trying to
chase after what you thought was cool
for that matter could you imagine eating
human brain no no neither of those
things amazing yeah I'm good I have no
interest a lot of the media that we get
today is like that though like my way
familiar with well it's not just that
it's like chasing after what they think
will be the hot thing right
and so this wrestler Reza ends up
becoming I guess just like fodder for
the machine
cuz you know CNN doesn't care yeah
there's like cancel his show that was
gross
yeah it's life that didn't work mom will
just fire him and move on but if you
look at other other companies like Mike
comm is a really good example okay I
don't know Mike calm started out as kind
of a libertarian like seriously like Pro
Ron polish okay and then became super
social justice it's just because they're
chasing after what they think the next
hot thing is and they will sacrifice and
burn down anybody so so actually
interestingly enough like Joe Rogan was
talking about this on a recent podcast
with well I came over the guy's name but
he was saying that you know CNN's doing
the things they're doing orange man bad
and all the stuff because they're
desperately trying to survive yeah you
look back to what they did with the
brain-eating and it's like yeah they've
been desperately trying to figure out
what they think people would be into
they're not cool
they're right there they're doing weird
weird stuff yeah we're trying but it's
not just about them it's like the whole
landscape is kind of derivative of what
we've seen from that moment Vice had
early success but vices success was not
in my opinion based upon actual popular
ideas like it wasn't based upon how do I
say success it was it was built upon the
perception of success people were
absolutely convinced that vice was cool
so everyone wanted to be vice and now
vice is like you know Disney's written
off their entire investment saying it's
worth less five hundred million dollars
in the toilet yeah yeah so like Disney
invested if like 500 million it was like
four hundred and another company
invested like 70 and then they merged
and then they wrote like last year we
now see that investment as nothing
completely written off we're never
getting back because it was an illusion
you know which is so so it's funny
because you have companies like Mike
they started I don't know exactly how
they started or what the deal was but
they started something like early 2010's
and Ron Paul was really big you know the
Ron Paul Love Revolution of 2008 you
know you ever seen the Ron Paul and like
the revolution but then it says love
backwards yeah okay it was huge in the
Internet and so right now you've got you
know Ron Paul recently said something
like doctor foul Qi needs to be fired
he's trying to take control of
everything and so like this reddit is
tearing him apart
pouchy Ron Paul and someone commented
this is funny remember when we all loved
Ron Paul and I'm curious like why did
that change yeah Ron Paul didn't change
he's still saying the same old same old
crazy
well they comment like we grew up okay
you grew up Mike calm my understanding
and I could be wrong about this started
out with some very libertarian stories
and then over time just trying to figure
out what would get the most traffic
turned into a social justice rage bait
outlet they the dudes who are running it
were like apparently libertarian brow as
far as I you know I was told by many
other people yeah so this is what's
actually driving politics in this
country yeah I know
yeah you've get you you get oh it's all
fake I guess you know so III I'm curious
real nowadays yeah nothing like this
story we're about to get into and we'll
jump back to super Ches real quick about
the guy who's saying like let it all
burn I don't believe any of it I don't
believe that it's real you know and
that's why I was good to this well let
me I got one more point I mentioned this
in a couple of my videos I mentioned it
yesterday and I say it I have no problem
saying it they pretend to be angry so we
pretend to be angry back right like how
I don't know you know sometimes I read
this stuff and I'm like it really does
bug me when the media lies about this
and then people make youtube videos
where they're like Tim Poole's wrong and
I'm like do you really care that I'm I
care about what the people in these news
companies are doing and saying or is it
just performative art to fit your
audience yep that's what I want that's
instantly what I go in my head yep
that's what it is like eating brain
catering to the masses yeah like eating
a brain I guess they thought they were
gonna get this big hit that's what you
know I've been in those meetings man
where people are like dude I have this
idea we're gonna do this crazy thing and
work and there and I've successfully
navigated away from all the crazy people
who have done the stupid things like
brain-eating or like I've been in the
meetings where they've pitched stuff
that's just factually wrong but they
don't care and I just refused I'm not
going to go down that road because
they're not thinking about the long term
where's
what this gonna do to them yeah like one
examples like I was at fusion and there
was this fake outrage over ghost in the
shell' do you know do you know ghost
Nichelle is
yeah so they were they were like ooh
this is really crazy like it's an anime
you know and they're doing a live-action
but they they cast a white woman to play
major Kusanagi I think the name is
moeldoko
and they're like whoa Wow and total
whitewashing and then I was like
actually I'm kind of a fan of ghost in
the shell' and I don't think that
actually makes sense like an aspect of
ghost in the shell' is that by cyber
izing your brain and getting prosthetic
bodies who transcend race and gender and
all these things and like it's actually
one of the questions like asked and
stand alone complex of major why does
she why does she prefer female bodies
and I'm like it's actually a better
question about like I guess maybe like
gender identity and they were like no we
think racism and I'm like you guys don't
know anything about this show now and so
that's the flak they ended up getting
when they write these fake articles is
that they're not actually talking about
things they know and are passionate
about they're trying to figure out how
they like they're trying to pretend to
be relevant yeah and so I guess to kind
of wrap wrap up that idea you end up
with the dude going to India and eating
brain and then it makes him go insane
and then he goes on Twitter and all he
is is just foaming at the mouth
screeching and everybody he's full of
hate and vile brain-eating madness to be
fair lots of them are like that I don't
think you could blame that on the brainy
no I do I write I know I think the
brain-eating that was the catalyst
wasn't he like some he was like a
scholar on a religion or something I
think he ruined his reputation realized
what he's done came back and was like
well I have to be a super social justice
warrior now or no one will ever listen
to me again
no I think it's that you know when you
go into Twitter and everyone hates you
and it's pointing the finger at you and
laughing at you you become resentful and
angry and you hate everyone and so he
just goes on Twitter and he just scowls
and like you had a show is about
religion that's how he ended up eating
the brain okay it was supposed to be
like a serious religious scholar now
he's become this putrid vile hunched
demon who just vomits on people on
Twitter mmm like he went from being
prestigious to just
yes that's what happens meet Brian man I
know I guess so so don't do that don't
eat brain thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you